[Music]
[Applause]
jordan schultz joining us uh an insider
with the nba and nfl broken a couple of
stories here as of late joins us on the
program let me start with that tyree
kill maybe on the move
what do you think can you believe this
off season so the key thing for me is
you know they have tried to find a a
number for him and have not been able to
get there so the fact that they're at
this point tells you that it's probably
pretty close they have reached out to a
ton of teams miami and kansas city are
the two that are most likely but to your
point dan he wants devante adam's money
he thinks he's the best receiver in the
league
he's been on my show he's basically said
as much the problem is kansas city
doesn't have a tremendous amount of cap
space and they believe brett beats the
gm does that they can win whoever it is
because they have patrick mahomes the
keynote here is marvin allen who's the
assistant gm who reports directly to
chris career in miami was the uh
assistant gm with kansas city and
director of scouting when they draft
entire kill so there's a history there
obviously the thought with miami is if
you compare hill with waddle you've
added a big time offense alignment in
tehran armstead suddenly even to your
point about tua maybe there's some magic
there
can the chief still keep him
they can still keep him if he if they'll
come up but i just don't see them coming
up even if it's a compromise of
somewhere in the middle 25 i don't know
if that's going to get it done they'd
ask i was i just got a text they've
asked for at least two number ones so
you talked about the number 10 pick from
the from the jets that's not going to do
it that's a tremendous amount to give up
for a wide receiver and to me
great as tyrique hill is to give up two
number ones and potentially more i don't
know if that's if that's the right move
what's the market for baker mayfield
it's not as good as jimmy garoppolo um
you know which surprised me because
garoppolo is coming off the shoulder
surgery
but to me
baker may feel like yes people think
number one pick heisman trophy winner he
played hurt there's still some upside
there so there is a market for him the
problem for him in cleveland is there's
just not a lot of teams left that need a
quarterback we've heard seattle i know
they've talked to cleveland i don't
think anything's gotten really serious
they still have drew lock and they still
have a free agent and geno smith to me
baker mayfield right now has played his
last down with cleveland but i'm just
not so sure the browns are in any
specific hurry to actually make a move
because they know the market for him is
not significant and they've waited right
they wanted to make sure they had a
quarterback they got their quarterback
into sean watson they signed your krobin
percent but now it's like okay do we
make a move just to make a move or if
i'm uh the gm do i just want to be a
little bit patient and see what i can
get
uh the pro days everybody has a great
pro day uh malik willis yesterday had a
great pro day i don't know if these
things mean anything though you know
when you're
i i love the personality that malik
willis showed on his pro day jordan yeah
okay
but you know everybody rolls left and
throws right 60 yards that's the thing
that's the new thing you have to do
they pro days don't mean anything to me
i want to know what you do in an actual
game so
it feels like there's a lot of love
maybe too much love for malik willis uh
what team makes sense for him
well
he him and kenny pickett have both
jumped up considerably
pickett's game film is better he had 41
touchdowns he won the johnny united
award willis i asked willis who i asked
about willis who struggled against
mississippi state this year because he
was a liberty i asked a couple people
you know does that hurt his stock and
the answer was no and i said why not
they said well look who's around him
he's not in a great program he didn't
have time to throw he doesn't have a
tremendous amount of talent around him
but he had a great pro day because he
made that same throw that zach wilson
and trevor lawrence did where they're
rolling out right and then they come
back left and they throw 60 yards off
platform now i'm not a quarterback guru
like carson palmer who's terrific and i
know he's on your show a lot but i asked
does that matter and guys said yeah
because you see that you're like oh what
can i do with that all these teams
believe they can make malik willis into
a great quarterback the same with kenny
pickett um i asked an nfc assistant gm
about pickett and he said the same thing
which is he's a really good athlete he
doesn't have the same arm as malik but
he's probably more ready right now i
think both of those guys are in the top
10 right now pittsburgh i know loves
both they're not going to be able to get
those guys in the early 20s so they
would have to move up you think both go
in the top ten
yes i do i think i think malik willis
can go as high as two and i don't think
pika gets outside the top ten that's
what nfc assistant gm told me a couple
days ago you could see the lions going
all in yes yeah the lions have their
stop gap and jared goff but they're
paying him a lot he's not the future i
think the lions you know they drafted
penne stool last year um and they they
need a quarterback i think
you know pittsburgh could move up
there's
the the only thing i'll say is this then
you start to think about oh matt corral
and some of these other guys carson
strong could you wait because there's
not that much of a difference all it
takes is one team to move up and love
you and as you know
teams get crazy around the draft
quarterbacks
talking to jordan schultz the shorts
report um nfl nba insider also co-host
of pull-up podcasts with cj mccollum
when's the last time you talked to cj
and uh have you brought up the zion
williamson dunk
yes i have we talked two days ago um you
know cj's from cleveland from ken he's a
big browns fan so i wanted to gauge his
reaction i think he believes as do many
that the browns are super bowl
contenders now at least if desean plays
so i know he's happy about cleveland um
i've asked him about zion because
remember when he got traded there
you know he told me i was involved in
the process fan with new orleans they i
knew they liked me i knew david griffin
was interested it was time to move on
he immediately talked to brandon niemer
but he did not hear from zion williamson
and i asked him that bobby because
zion's supposed to be the face of the
franchise and he said no we eventually
hashed it out i did not ask him about
the dunk you're talking about like the
the 360 or whatever you want between his
legs yeah
i didn't ask him about that but i did
say what's your gauge on zen zion he
said he's a really good kid
people forget he's 21 22 years old and
he's been the number one player in the
country since he's 15 years old and
there's something to be said about that
i don't just on the big picture here i
don't know if zion williamson's ever
ever played for the pelicans again he's
played 85 games in his career
if you don't trade him this summer dan
what are you going to get for him long
term and if you don't believe he's going
to stay healthy what are you going to
what are we talking about here
you think that zion has played his last
game in new orleans i think there's a
very good chance he will not be back and
they will trade him this summer or at
least strongly explore trades yes
what could you get for zion williamson
you can get right now a lottery pick no
question about it you drafted a number
one do you get that back absolutely not
he's still very young he averaged 27
points a game last year he was terrific
you remember he was shooting threes and
he was passing and you thought okay i
can see it you can still get a lottery
pick for him but if you're in new
orleans and you're trying to build you
have herb jones who's a good young
player you have cj you have brandon
ingram you need one more piece but he's
got to be available and zion has not
been available okay but is this because
you don't think you can sign him or
or that he's damaged goods
the latter ladder because
he has significant weight problems we've
seen the reports oh he's over 300 pounds
he's 290 always back to 310 you've seen
the pictures
he hasn't been around the team this year
either and from what i've heard he's a
really good kid but he's been in
portland working out and trying to rehab
i've you know i've heard great things
he's been in it he's finally back in new
orleans now you know maybe
maybe he can play early next season but
the bottom line is you cannot
extend him if you're in new orleans
given that he's basically played one
season in almost three you just can't do
it at this point
great stuff jordan great to connect with
you again thanks for joining us
dan it's my pleasure and i owe you a
beer because we've been in the super
bowl and i lost yeah well
i i i felt bad for you because i love
the bengals but i said the bengals
aren't winning the super bowl and you
being right i was wrong yeah well you're
an nfl insider right
i i try to be and i also want to say go
flyers my mom's from lima ohio all right
well thank you jordan thanks for joining
us jordan schultz the shorts schultz
schwartz schultz report um also co-host
of pull-up podcast with cj mccollum also
host of game plan on kevin durant's
boardroom